alessandro thank you very much for a
great talk and
it's my great pleasure to introduce
daniel daniel
is a very fresh uh phd graduate so he
completed his phd in 2019 which is
actually now two years
although it feels it was just a couple
of days back
he is now a professor at the university
of california
at santa cruz and i have to daniel
refer maybe more to your phd uh
achievements when
daniel was a star student his advice at
berkeley
his advisor was uh sanji shesha that
uh he managed daniel managed to get all
sorts of work
he got like a distinguished researcher
for award
from university of berkeley he got nsf
graduate research fellowship which is
a very prestigious fellowship given only
to the best applicant
he gets best paper award at uh
conference on internet of things so
without further ado since we are a
little bit uh behind the schedule
daniel i give floor to you and i'm
looking forward to your talk
thank you rujika can you see my slides
yes we can see okay great and i will try
to stay
on time here all right uh so hi
everybody
uh i'm daniel fremont uh today i'm going
to
talk about algorithmic improvisation
which is a mathematical
framework for synthesizing randomized
systems
so why do we care about randomization in
systems so use peter gave a great
example
uh earlier of using randomness to get
robustness that would not
otherwise be possible in a deterministic
protocol
but there are actually many reasons why
systems uh use randomness in fact depend
on randomness to achieve
not only robustness but maybe variety or
unpredictability
so let's look at some examples from very
different areas
so one would be suppose you have some
neural network which is supposed to take
images like these
and detect objects in these images
and you want to generate training or
testing data for this network so you
the task is to generate images of
bumper-to-bumper traffic
say that's a huge space of possibilities
these three images are very different
from each other
but all meet that high level description
of bumper-to-bumper traffic
and we can use randomness to cover that
space evenly
we'll come back to this example later
another reason why you might need
randomness is realism so for instance
let's say you want to design
a lighting controller for a house that
mimics the
user's typical behavior when they're on
vacation if you
had a deterministic model for that it
would be unrealistic because human
behavior is inherently random some days
you wake up a little bit later some days
maybe you cook more or less
and so you really need a stochastic
model to uh
faithfully represent the humans behavior
a third example would be using
randomness for unpredictability
say you have some surveillance robot
that's supposed to patrol
different rooms in a museum uh it's got
some other constraints maybe you know
has to recharge
these kinds of things if you solve those
constraints you found a policy that was
deterministic and you had a single route
for patrolling the museum
then it might be that every night at 2
am the robot's at one end of the museum
and the thieves will break in on the
other end of the museum
but if you use the random route that
would make the robot's future prediction
harder
a future location harder to predict
while at the same time of course we
still want to correct by construction
plan
so we'll also come back to this example
but the point to see
is that in all of these systems
randomness is really essential for the
proper operation of those systems
but at the same time they need to
satisfy formal specifications
so in the lighting control example maybe
you want to use at most a certain amount
of power
each day in the image generation you
have realism constraints like objects
should not intersect
for instance and in robotic planning
you've got safety specifications like
don't collide with some other drone
that's moving around
the same space so there's this general
question then of how can we design a
system
that uses randomness but still has
controlled behavior so how can we
synthesize a system that can make use of
randomness
and that's what algorithmic
improvisation is really about
it's a framework for automatically
synthesizing systems which could be
reactive systems
that have a random behavior but formal
guarantees
so like in ordinary correct by
construction
synthesis we have safety or other
guarantees which have to be
satisfied the new thing is we also have
a guarantee of
randomness so we'll have some
constraints saying
the behavior of the system has to be
random in some sense
and the fundamentally new thing here is
that randomness is really part of the
system specification
and that makes this a different problem
from say reactive synthesis that's been
studied a lot
and so we really do need new techniques
although as we'll see we'll build on
classic work on synthesis
and on uniform sampling from constraints
okay so just to outline this talk i'm
going to start by defining
the core computational problem in this
area of algorithmic improvisation which
we call control improvisation
and i'll illustrate that with some
examples and then i'll give you a quick
overview of the theory of this problem
that we've developed both efficient
algorithms and
complexity hardness results and then
i'll talk
in a little bit more detail about an
interesting application of this area
that we've been working on the last few
years
of using improvisation to design and
analyze
autonomous systems particularly systems
that use machine learning
and finally i'll wrap up with some
directions for ongoing work
okay so to start uh with uh control
improvisation here oops
animation silly there all right so
to motivate the definition let me go
into a little bit more detail about this
robotic surveillance
example that i mentioned before so if
the task that you have
is to patrol an area in an unpredictable
way
you have various different types of
specifications
so you want to do a construct correct by
construction synthesis but what are the
specs for that synthesis
so you have a typical type of
specification like maybe
you need to visit each of these various
locations that are important
sufficiently often you know typical type
of spec we could encode in ltl or
something like that
you might also have a constraint like
take a route close to the shortest one
maybe you don't want to take the
shortest one because maybe it's unique
and then there wouldn't be any
unpredictability but it should be fairly
close to the shortest possible route
and then you might have a yet third type
of constraint
saying don't always take the same route
we actually want some unpredictability
in this
and the thing to notice is that these
are three very different types of
constraints
the first is what we call a hard
constraint this is something that has to
be true all the time
whereas this constraint only needs to be
true to some extent
it's sort of a soft constraint and this
third constraint is not a constraint on
individual behaviors at all but it
really it's a constraint on the
distribution of behaviors of the system
so in this application and it turns out
in quite a few other applications so the
couple that i mentioned before
but some others that i won't really get
into in this talk like music
improvisation which is where
the name of this uh problem came from in
the first place
also software fuzz testing other k
things like that
you all they all have this same type of
form if you want to synthesize some
sequence of actions or decisions
something like that subject to three
different types of constraints
a hard constraint which everything you
generate has to satisfy
a soft constraint which most things you
generate have to satisfy
and some randomness constraints saying
you can't just generate the same thing
over and over again
and there wasn't really a problem
already in the literature that
simultaneously captured all three of
these
so that's why we defined this new
problem we call control improvisation
the idea is it gives a
a precise grounded definition that lets
you study
synthesis problems of this form so let
me
uh introduce a bit of notation before we
can define the problem
let's think about this robotic planning
example so maybe you have a drone
over here that's supposed to visit these
four circles
while avoiding maybe some other drone
here we'll come back to that later
and maybe it has to avoid this central
spot as well
and we'll say that the plan for the
robot will be described by a sequence of
actions it could take
moving in this grid world so we'll have
a finite alphabet
sigma of four actions from moving north
south east and west
and let's say we want to generate a plan
of link 30. so 30 of these
actions i'll just say fixed length for
simplicity but we can also handle you
know up to some bounded length
our hard constraints will be given by
some specification
h where i'm being deliberately vague
about what i mean by specification it
could be temporal logic it could be an
automaton
the complexity of the problem will
depend on what type of specification
you have so here the example could be
visit all of the four
circles while avoiding collisions with
this other robot
that could be our hard specification and
we'll have our soft constraint
given by another specification s which
in this case let's say
it's don't visit the same circle twice
because that would be redundant so we
don't want to do that too often
okay so now given uh these
specifications
h and s for the hard and soft
constraints
we'll define a few sets so if we think
of the universe of all possible
sequences of actions we could generate
so this is
sequences of n symbols from this
alphabet sigma
this includes trajectories like this
where maybe the two robots collide with
each other
so that is not allowed because that
violates our hard constraint
so we're going to pick out a subset of
this space which is the subset
satisfying this hard constraint h
so they're in the language of that
specification we're going to call those
the improvisations or the set
i now that set also contains things that
are safe maybe they satisfy the hard
constraint
but they violate the soft constraints so
like here this path
visits this circle twice so we're going
to call
that an inadmissible improvisation and
we'll have a further subset
a of admissible improvisations these are
the ones that satisfy both the heart and
the soft constraint
so here for example this plan visits all
four circles and it doesn't visit any of
them twice
so that would be an admissible
improvisation and that's in this set a
right so keeping this picture in mind of
these different sets
now we can set up the definition of a
control improvisation problem
so given uh the hard and soft constraint
this length bound n
and a couple of other parameters so
we're going to have an error probability
epsilon
which is going to say basically how
often you're allowed to violate the soft
constraint
and some probability bounds lambda and
rho that will be used to constrain how
much randomness there is
we'll see in a second we'll say that a
distribution
over words is an improvising
distribution if it satisfies three
conditions
so the hard constraint says that if you
sample a word from this distribution
it has to satisfy this hard
specification h that is it has to be an
improvisation
with probability one the soft constraint
is similar it says if you sample a word
it has to be an admissible improvisation
so in this further subset a most of the
time
so at least you know one minus epsilon
probability so you can tune
how tight this constraint is by picking
epsilon
and finally to enforce randomness we'll
say that every word that you could
generate
so every improvisation its probability
has to be
at least lambda and at most row
so this would allow you for example to
say that nothing is generated too
frequently
by picking some small value of row so if
you picked rho is
one in a million then nothing can be
generated with probability greater than
one in a million
uh in this talk just to simplify things
i'm going to assume lambda is zero but
you can check out our papers for the
more general definitions
okay so given all of this data uh the
hard and soft constraint
specifications and these parameters we
call that an instance of control
improvisation
and we say it's feasible if one of these
distributions exists
and then what we want is an algorithm
that samples from such a distribution
which we call an improviser
and so the synthesis problem here is
given one of these instances given the
specifications
construct an improviser an algorithm
that samples
from a distribution that satisfies all
of these constraints
and the reason why this might be
difficult is that these sets i
and a might only be described implicitly
maybe by a boolean formula or something
like that
they might be exponentially large so we
can't just enumerate these sets to come
up with our policy
so let's look at an example suppose for
instance
you had three different admissible
improvisations and two other
improvisations which were not admissible
then if we set epsilon and rho to one
quarter for instance so this would be
saying
you're allowed to violate the soft
constraint a quarter of the time
and no individual improvisation that you
generate should have probability greater
than a quarter
and we'll say lambda equals zero then
this is an example of an improvising
distribution
pick one of these three behaviors with
probability one quarter each
and one of these two other behaviors
with probability
1 8 each and if we did that
then that satisfies the hard constraint
because we're always generating one of
these five things that's an
improvisation we're not generating
anything out here
it satisfies the soft constraint because
we get something that's admissible with
probability three quarters
and we have epsilon equals one quarter
and
no individual behavior is ever generated
with probability more than
uh more than one quarter which was rho
so this would satisfy
our three constraints and so it would be
an improvising distribution
okay so this is the definition of the
problem in the static
setting now if you want to do reactive
synthesis now we have to generalize this
a bit because we have an adversary
so just briefly outline how we change
the definition i just gave
so suppose now same kind of example we
had before but now this other robot
maybe you don't control it it can move
around arbitrarily
and you need to make sure you avoid
collisions anyway so
we will now set up uh the problem as a
two-player game as we saw in earlier
talks this morning uh standard
formalism and synthesis where the system
and the adversary alternate picking
symbols or actions at each step we'll
still have
all three of those constraints the hard
the soft and randomist constraint
but now they need to hold regardless of
what the adversary does
so we'll say for all possible
adversaries those three constraints
still hold
and now our notion of an improviser will
become an improvising strategy
instead of just sampling from this
distribution all at once
it will pick one action and then it
takes its input the environment's
response and then it picks its next
action and so forth
and once you do this this gives you a
way to do reactive synthesis
in a randomized manner at least for a
bounded
time interval so as an example of that
we saw these animations before what
these were actually showing are some
simulations using our
algorithm for rci that i'll talk a
little bit about later
to solve this kind of surveillance
problem where the robot in the
bottom left is the one we're controlling
it has to visit these four
circles while avoiding collisions with
an adversary which is the blue
dashed line and just to show you the
randomness in all four of these
simulations i've had the adversary move
in the same way
on the grid world and because of the
physics it's not moving in exactly the
same way each time
but it's ba it's making the same path
through the grid world and you'll see
that our improviser the black line is
responding in a very different way each
time
while still satisfying all of these
constraints that we see on the left
and here we were actually using a
randomness requirement saying make
row as small as possible while still
satisfying the other constraints
so in some sense this is the maximally
randomized policy
and our algorithm actually allows you to
compute this smallest feasible row
okay so this gives you an idea of the
problem definition
and now let me tell you a little bit
about uh the theory of control
improvisation
oops okay so the first question you
could ask is when can you
solve one of these problems and it turns
out that feasibility just requires these
sets i
and a to be large enough at least with
lambda equals zero which is what we're
talking about here
so in particular a ci instance with
lambda equals zero
is feasible if and only if these two
sets are sufficiently large
and the idea behind these inequalities
is basically that if these sets are too
small
you may be able to solve the problem but
not in a random enough way
so if there's only one way to solve the
constraints for instance
then you can't possibly have a random
strategy because you have to just
generate that one thing
that satisfies the constraints and so
the analysis basically shows you how you
need to trade off
the size of these sets versus the
epsilon and row that you're requiring
and where this proof basically comes out
of or it's kind of a consequence of this
of the construction we use in the proof
is that we actually can give a
quite generic algorithm for doing
control improvisation
that doesn't really care about what the
constraints are represented as
as long as you can implement a few
abstract operations
so if you can efficiently intersect and
take the difference of two
specifications
restrict one to a given length and then
more interestingly
count the number of words that satisfy a
specification
and uniformly sample from those words
both of which could be highly
non-trivial for example
if the specification is a boolean
formula then this is the model counting
problem or the
uniform generation problem but if you
can do all of these things
then there is a polynomial time if you
can do all of these in polynomial time
then there's a polynomial time synthesis
algorithm
and the way it works is we use these
first three operations
to construct those sets that we need
these sets
i a and i minus a so the inadmissible
improvisations
we construct specifications for those we
can count them
and then check those inequalities on the
previous slide if they're not satisfied
then we know the problem is impossible
to solve
if they are satisfied it turns out
there's a very simple
way to do the sampling uh to get a
an improvising distribution which is you
just pick uniformly
from either the admissible or the
inadmissible
improvisations with the right
probabilities so you flip a weighted
coin to decide which of these two sets
to use
and then you sample from them uniformly
at random and if you pick the right
weighted coin
you will satisfy all of those
constraints we had before
so this again is for the static case
and now we can plug into this general
procedure
techniques for counting and sampling
when we know how to do those efficiently
and get
algorithms so for example we get
polynomial time improvisation schemes
for deterministic finite automata which
are useful
for examples in say music robotic
planning
we can use classic techniques for
counting and sampling from automata here
likewise uh say if you want to do fuzz
testing for
testing some software maybe from
generative fuzz testing from a grammar
you might want to use as a specification
a context free grammar
and if the grammar is unambiguous then
again we get
polynomial time algorithms using
techniques for a sampling from grammars
so this is the kind of picture we get
that if the hard constraint
is a finite automaton a deterministic
finite automaton or a grammar
the same thing for the soft constraint
we get polynomial time
algorithms in some of these cases but
for more complicated ones
the problem becomes hard so for
non-deterministic automata or for
ambiguous grammars
or actually even if you have unambiguous
grammars but both the hard and soft
constraint are given by grammars
the problem becomes essentially
equivalent in complexity to
the class sharp p the counting problems
so we still actually in that case have
approximation algorithms for the problem
so for instance if your specs are
boolean formulas then this is clearly
sharply hard
but using sat solvers and recent
techniques for
approximate counting and sampling we can
still give
approximation algorithms for the problem
okay so this was all in the static case
uh if you want to solve this in the
reactive case it's interesting
uh feasibility again reduces to counting
you can think of it as you know you want
to find a winning strategy in the
synthesis game
but now just finding a single strategy
is not
if maybe it is not necessarily enough it
could be that maybe the adversary can
force you to play in only one way to win
if there's only one way to win then
again you can't have a randomized policy
so there in fact need to be sufficiently
many ways to win that game
and the result we get is actually
extremely similar to what we had before
it's just now instead of the size of
these sets in a
we have this new notion of size which we
call the width
and the way that works is it the width
basically counts
the number of winning plays minimized
over all possible adversaries
so here's the definition what we say is
we maximize over all possible
strategies for us the improviser then we
minimize
over all strategies of the adversary
of this inner quantity and this notation
here is saying the probability of
getting a particular trace
w given the strategies of the two
players
so what we'll do is count what are all
the traces that have
non-zero probability given these two
strategies
and we want to make that as large as
possible and the adversary wants to make
it as small as possible
so this is what we call the width so the
width of x is the
basically the maximum number of plays
that we can ensure
are possible to play what regardless of
what the adversary does uh
so once you have this we get the same
kind of inequalities we had before
constructing an improviser turns out to
be a lot more involved than in the
non-reactive case that i described
before in particular it turns out that
the strategy cannot be memoryless even
if you have just like a safety
specification
where it's known you have memoryless
strategies normally
here the need to have to do it randomly
actually requ forces you in some way to
ha
to need some memory but the way our
strategy works is essentially does a
kind of random walk
remembering the widths so you construct
the game graph
here and the numbers that are being
shown in this example
are the widths so if you have the
winning states then you have one way to
win from there
and so basically if you minimize at the
adversary controlled states
and some at the states you control this
gives you a dynamic programming kind of
way to compute the width
so here we can work out that from the
initial state we have
a way to win at least four different
ways the adversary may be able to make
us win in
in you know uh um
more ways than that but certainly we can
guarantee at least four different ways
to win the game
and this gives a dynamic programming way
to compute those
and then uh doing this random walk plus
a little bit more complication because
this would be a memoryless strategy we
have to do a little bit more
uh we end up giving getting away to once
you can compute these widths
do a improvising strategy
and so that gives us a similar sort of
picture of the complexity
if you have dfa specifications which
includes things like safety and
reachability
objectives we can again do this in
polynomial time so we can do like
randomized reactive synthesis for
reachability games in polynomial time
but for things like non-deterministic
automata and
even more generally uh temporal logics
uh
it becomes p space equivalent uh and
here if
those of you familiar with reactive
synthesis um
you may wonder why is it only p space
for ltl versus like doubly exponential
time
it's because of this bounded wind length
window so everything's in the bounded
window so it's only p space hard
so uh this gives you a picture of the
theory of control improvisation and the
last thing that i want to
mention i've got like oh just a couple
more minutes here so let me wrap up
is i want to highlight uh an application
that was building off some of the idea
ideas i presented here that we've been
working on recently
namely uh using oops improvisation to
design and analyze machine learning
systems
so the motivating example here is if you
want to test something like a
self-driving car
it has a camera maybe that's taking
images like this it's
gathering data about a very complex
environment
and we'll define the environment
configuration
so not the pixels but the configuration
of where these cars are and so forth as
a scene
even if you think of that high level of
scenes not pixels
uh these have a complex structure so
collecting examples
of these real world scenes is expensive
but
it's also difficult to generate them
automatically for training or testing
purposes
because the space of possible
scenes is so large so you've got all
types of different parameters like the
positions of the objects the types of
objects and so forth
so it's a very large and unstructured
space if you just generate randomly
you'll get things that don't really make
sense physically
realistic scenes have complex geometric
constraints like cars tend to drive in
lanes for example
and furthermore you might be interested
in particular types of scenes like
highway traffic
bumper-to-bumper traffic so you want to
generate only things that meet
your specifications and so that's again
it's
reminiscent of an instance of control
improvisation
where we have uh specifications saying
what types of
data we'd like to randomly generate the
complexity here though is that while we
again have hard and soft constraints
like objects should not intersect
clearly we might have a soft constraint
like 20 percent of images should be at
night
we need more complex randomness
requirements like we might want to say
that the distance between cars should
follow
this particular distribution that we
learned from data
and that doesn't fit into the definition
i gave before so we need a formalism
that can express
that type of constraint and a natural
one for that is a probabilistic
programming language
and so that's what we've done last few
years is we've developed a language
called
scenic which is a domain-specific
probabilistic programming language
for defining a distribution over scenes
and the behaviors of the objects in
those scenes
so for example bumper-to-bumper traffic
that example i started the talk with
these images were generated from a short
program in scenic it's a single scenic
program
that we're sampling multiple times and
getting these different images from
and scenic makes it possible to define
these kind of complicated
uh complicated scenes easily
by giving you concise syntax for common
geometric relationships
and the domain specific nature of scenic
also gives us
more efficient sampling algorithms that
i won't talk about here
while still giving you the modeling
convenience of probabilistic programming
by a being able to impose declarative
hard and soft constraints
so i'm out of time here so i'll just
mention quickly that
we have some case studies using this for
example
finding bugs in aircraft control systems
you know getting confused by shadows
things like that
and then actually fixing those problems
by generating synthetic data using
scenic
we've also used this these techniques
to look at self-driving car software
finding errors
in simulation and then reproducing them
on an actual test track with the real
car
so just to conclude algorithmic
improvisation is a framework for
randomized synthesis which has various
applications
uh including some that i didn't have
time to get into in this talk like fuzz
testing
music improvisation human modeling and
so forth in particular it has
applications to
the design of safe autonomous systems
like through controller synthesis or
synthetic data generation
also there's applications through human
modeling that i mentioned right at the
beginning
there have been some colleagues of ours
have used this for example to learn
human models of
models of how humans make lane changes
for instance
and we there's various directions for
ongoing work that we're working on for
instance generalizing the problem to
allow
further types of soft constraints or
randomness constraints
more sophisticated than the ones i
talked about here and also in another
kind of synthesis
synthesizing senior programs themselves
from data rather than writing them by
hand
if you're interested in this please go
to our website we have
lots of these examples there and links
to our papers and and uh our tools
all right i'll stop here and i'm happy
to take questions
great doctor i'm clapping for everyone
daniel thank you for the nice
presentation
i just realized that in some settings
the equivalent of chairs standing up
is actually chair starting to unmute
herself for himself
so let me just give the others i have a
couple of questions that they asked but
i know that i
don't want to this is there someone else
who would like to ask a quick question
actually i see that uh saleh has asked
one in the chat
um oh please yeah uh so he
okay so let's see so he's asked um
uh right so the soft constraints unlike
the heart constraints can be violated
to some extent um and
the how what do you define like the
cut-off point uh between you know when
it becomes
infeasible even though you know you're
allowed to violate it to some extent
right so the
the idea is that in our definition let
me go back
to that um
in the definition here how often you're
allowed to violate this so how often the
word you generate is allowed to not be
admissible
is controlled by this epsilon so if
there's a way of satisfying it say you
know if epsilon is a quarter
then if there's a way of satisfying this
constraint three quarters of the time
while still being sufficiently random
then the problem would be feasible
whereas there's kind of a there's a
trade-off between the heart the soft
constraint and the randomness constraint
because
it could be that if you're in a
situation like this one here
if you only have three ways to satisfy
this say
but if we have a row of one quarter we
can't just generate each of these three
with probability one-third
if we did that then we would always
satisfy the soft constraint
but we would generate some things with
probability one-third
whereas we're only allowed to generate
things with probability up to one
quarter
so here we have to actually throw in
some of these inadmissible ones that
violate the soft constraint
in order to satisfy the randomness
requirement
but if we can do that without going
beyond this error probability epsilon
that we're given
then we say the problem is still
feasible even though we had to throw in
some of these things that satisfied
that violated the soft constraint
hopefully that clarifies things
okay uh let's actually stop here
uh and it was really great talk i will
then i'll send you a thank you about my
question uh
later on because uh it's also weird
already
around half an hour after after the uh
schedule so thank you everyone and uh
see you again next monday bye thank you
very much
all the participants yeah thanks and
especially the speakers
bye guys daniel can i ask you now
so you show this i think i've seen all
your this talk before about cynic and i
think you